game delays aren't rare and as the year
goes on the list of games delayed in
2022 has only grown larger from
starfield to redfall so to help keep it
all straight we've compiled a list of
all the games delayed so far a quick
note before we get started though is
that only games with delays across all
available systems have been included but
with that said enough delay let's get to
the list
[Music]
red out two the futuristic high octane
racer red out 2 will be hitting the
accelerator a little bit later than
planned scheduled to launch in may 2022
the game was delayed just before its
original release to june 16th it's not a
huge delay but you'll have to keep
playing the original for a little bit
longer before this one hits the finish
line
to chia
sorry had to do it anyways to chia has
been delayed to next year with the quote
control anything adventure game needing
more polish and a chance to add a little
details according to the announcement
the game has been in development for
more than three years thus far and it
also comes with a fully playable ukulele
that has both gameplay and creative
implications which is enough for me to
know that it'll be worth the wait
test drive a limited solar crown the
next entry in the test drive unlimited
series will no longer arrive in 2022
test drive unlimited solar crown takes
550 kilometers of a hong kong island and
makes it playable in a driving lifestyle
game and the development team stressed
that polish is especially important
looks like this one will need a few more
tests before we can drive
kerbal space program 2 the sequel to the
acclaimed space flight simulation kerbal
space program will not be arriving in
2022 kerbal space program 2 will arrive
in early 2023 on pc followed by a
console release later that year with
intercept games emphasizing quality and
polish as the primary reasons for the
delay
starfield one of the biggest games of
2022 will now be one of the biggest
games of 2023 bethesda's starfield had
set a date november 11 2022 in order to
mirror skyrim's memorable 11 11 11
release date but sadly this won't be
like star wars as no longer will these
release dates rhyme again it's like
poetry so that they rhyme the game will
now be released at some point in 2023
with a new final release date to be
determined bethesda gave a vague polish
explanation for the delay in an update
post on social media in early may 2022
redfall speaking of bethesda their other
planned 2022 game redfall was delayed at
the same time as starfield and also
received a 2023 release window the
cooperative action game is being
developed by arcane austin and looks to
differ significantly from the studio's
work on dishonored and prey it will also
be the first arcane game to not be
released on a playstation system in more
than a decade as the xbox acquisition of
bethesda starts to bear fruit for the
console
the day before more like the day after
am i right okay look i gotta get my
enjoyment somewhere when talking about
delays the highly anticipated mmo the
day before was scheduled to launch in
june but the development team opted to
make a big change now to accommodate a
switch to unreal engine 5 the day before
will arrive on march 1
2023 studio fantastic promises a quote
more advanced and adapted open worlds
engine that will make the gameplay of
the day before even more fantastic
mx vs atv legends mx vs atv legends was
previously planned to release on may
24th however the game was delayed about
a month ahead of that to june 28th the
delay was made in order to preserve
quality including eliminating bugs and
keeping the frame rate high so it looks
like mx and atv will have to wait a bit
longer before they duke it out like king
kong vs godzilla
[Music]
the witcher 3 current generation the
witcher 3 released back in 2015 for last
gen systems and ps5 and xbox series x
and s versions are in development
however cd projekt red opted to move
development to its internal team rather
than continuing working with saber
interactive the decision has resulted in
the game moving from its q2 2022 window
to an unannounced future q4 2022 date
while disappointing given the disastrous
reception of cyberpunk 2077 due to its
buggy state at release any delay from
cdpr is likely to be the right call
to point campus the university
management simulator two point campus
was previously supposed to be out on may
17th but it appears two-point studios
ran into quality issues with some of its
supported platforms the game is now
coming on august 9th with game director
mark weebley saying the delay will let
the team quote deliver the best possible
game that can be enjoyed on all
platforms end quote so you do have a bit
longer to get your admission essays
submitted
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
sequel previously planned to launch at
some point in 2022 the legend of zelda
breath of the wild sequel will now
release in spring 2023 nintendo didn't
give a specific reason for the delay
though with any zelda game the reason
can usually amount to making sure it's
perfect the sequel will include gameplay
in the air as well as the ground and it
sports the same visual style as breath
of the wild
sons of the forest the much anticipated
follow-up to the forest was originally
planned to launch in may but sons of the
forest developer and night games now
says that window was overly ambitious
the survival game is now scheduled to
arrive in october and given its spooky
themes this new window might just
actually be the perfect choice
suicide squad kill the justice league
rocksteady's first full-length game
since batman arkham knight needs a
little bit more time to cook scheduled
for a 2022 release previously the
developer announced suicide squad kill
the justice league will now be arriving
in 2023 the game features characters
like harley quinn and deadshot and it's
technically a narrative sequel to arkham
knight unlike the game gotham knights
which isn't set in the same universe i
know
confusing
ea sports pga tour talk about a double
bogey after already delaying the game
once with an expected release window of
late 2022 ea has opted to delay ea
sports pga tour a second time and will
have to do without the tiger woods name
once again the golf legend has switched
teams and is now working exclusively
with 2k games
starship troopers tear in command if
there's any game that needs to have its
bugs squashed it's starship troopers
tear in command based on the amazing
cult classic sci-fi satire film which
was itself based on a non-satirical book
of dubious morality the game was
supposed to release at the end of march
however it will now arrive on june 16th
it's currently content complete but the
development team didn't want to have to
fix it post-launch with further patches
well i expect the best and i give the
best now have fun that's an
order advanced wars one plus two reboot
camp this one hurt less than two months
before it was due to release december
3rd 2021 advanced wars oneplus 2 reboot
camp was pushed back to april it was
then pushed back just a month before
launch in response to world events
almost certainly meaning the war in
ukraine far more than a remaster this
complete remake of the two game boy
advanced era advance wars games sports a
new art style and support for up to four
players given how long it's been since
the series last game a few more months
of waiting feels like nothing at this
point
stalker 2 heart of chernobyl planned
previously for an april 22 launch the
long-awaited stalker 2 has been delayed
to december 8th the 7 months are
according to gsc gameworld needed to
quote fulfill its vision and achieve the
desired state of the game end quote
based on its announcement it appears the
majority of this time will be spent on
testing and polishing but the game will
launch on game pass when it does come
out that being said however development
was temporarily sidelined following the
russian invasion of ukraine as gst game
world studios is based in kiev while the
developers have recently restarted work
on the game it wouldn't be surprising if
another delay might be on the horizon
frontier's warhammer age of sigmar rts
can a game be delayed if it doesn't have
a final name yet apparently so as
frontier development has announced its
previously teased warhammer age of
sigmar will now likely not arrive until
later in 2023 but this should be fine
for warhammer fans as they have quite a
few of those games to play in the
interim
rumbleverse only just announced in
december 2021 at the game awards iron
galaxy's rumbleverse has already been
delayed it will no longer release in
february as previously planned and the
beta test has also been pushed back to
an unspecified date no replacement
release date has been set yet with the
team saying it wants to build a great
community for the game and needs to
quote make sure we can get that right
the settlers the off delayed strategy
game the settlers has been delayed again
this time indefinitely previously
planned to launch on march 17th the game
was pushed back to an undetermined
future date after the game's closed beta
received criticism ubisoft dusseldorf is
using the time to quote improve the game
and push quality as its main priority
for all players looks like the settlers
will need more time to get settled i
know hate me in the comments i had to do
it
for spoken square enix and luminous
productions originally planned to launch
four spoken in may but the decision was
made to further add polish and make
improvements a few months before that
date now the game is coming on october
11th for ps5 and pc offering a unique
take on fantasy and magic in an action
adventure game
and that's the list of every game
delayed in 2022 which game on this list
were you most looking forward to and
which hurt the most to hear of its delay
which of my jokes were the worst ones to
hear themselves let us know all that in
the comments and don't forget to
subscribe so you don't miss our coverage
of these games whenever they release
right here on gamespot until then thank
you for watching
you